لقياس نشاط السائل المنوي لدى الرجل يجرى
بالاعتماد على ما يعرف بتكسير الحمض
النووي التحليل يقيس ماده الدي ان ايه في
السائل المنوي كما يرصد الاجزاء الجينيه
غير المتضرره والسبب هو انه كلما كان
الحمض النووي اكثر تعرضا للتفتيت
والانقسام نقصت جوده الحيوانات المنويه
وتراجعت قدرتها على الاخصاب كما يمكن ان
يؤدي الى فشل الحمل في حال تفتته بشكل
كبير فلا يكمل الجنين المده العاديه في
الرحم بحسب المعايير الطبيه فانه في حال
كان تكسير الماده الوراثيه في السائل
المنوي اقل من 25% فانه يظل في حاله
ممتازه وفي حال تخطى عتبه الخمسين بالمئه
فان الاخصاب الصناعي عنه يكون اهداف فرصه
ضعيفه
وتشير التقارير الى ان عدد من الاسباب
تؤثر سلبا على الحيوانات المنويه لدى
الرجل وهي التلوث والتدخين والعمر وبعض
الامراض
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات